- Well, today's show is about boss lady.
So do you have a boss lady
who's inspired you in your life?
- You know what? I,
I'm still obsessed with Shonda Rhimes.
- Did you see Bridgerton.
- Did I?!
My friend directed the pilot.
And I was like, girl, tell me everything.
- Oh my gosh.
- Obsessed, Obsessed
(laughing)
- It's so good. I love how
she incorporates music.
It's like contemporary,
- Yeah
- but she kind of makes it like you know,
- It was great
- with the orchestra
playing, it was really
really cool
- Yeah, she was telling me how they were
how they chose to shoot
those ballroom scenes.
And it was, it was a difficult choice
but they were happy with the way they
how it went because
everything was choreographed.
And so if they had to do a
pickup in the middle of a line
the dancers had to be where they were
in the middle of a line.
I mean, they got through it but
- Yeah, it was well done though.
I mean, everybody loves it
and she's a true boss lady
and just building an empire.
Yeah. So, so incredibly gifted.